der britische premierminister johnson
hat bei der parlamentswahl mit seinen
konservativen tories die absolute
mehrheit im unterhaus erobert johnson
bezeichnete das als starkes neues mandat
für den dreck sitz er könnte damit
großbritannien bis zum ablauf der
geltenden frist am 31 januar aus der
europäischen union herausführen
labour-chef corbijn kündigte als
konsequenz aus der niederlage an nicht
noch mal als spitzenkandidat anzutreten
andreas stamm in london was bedeutet
dieser klare sieg der konservativen
jetzt für den eu austritt
das ist einen klaren fahrplan gibt am
kommenden freitag noch vor weihnachten
wird boris johnson dem neu
zusammengesetzten parlament sein braig
citydeal also das mit der eu
ausgehandelte austritts abkommen
vorlegen
die zustimmung gilt als absolut sicher
nach dieser nacht und dann wird der 31
januar wohl der tag an dem
großbritannien die eu endgültig verlässt
dann beginnt die übergangsphase die soll
bis ende 2020 dauern
in der sich erstmal nichts grundlegend
ändert außer dass großbritannien die
politischen institutionen der eu
verlässt also im rat kommission und im
europäischen parlament eben nicht mehr
mitmischt und in dieser übergangsphase
in diesem cup zwölf monaten soll dann
die künftigen beziehungen ausverhandelt
werden experten halten das für völlig
illusorisch in so kurzer zeit fordern
schon jetzt eine verlängerung dieser
übergangsperiode das hat boris johnson
kategorisch ausgeschlossen dass heißt
fazit der brh exit wird kommen aber das
drama endet noch lange nicht